SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES- TO
ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON I WILL
START BY MAKING SEVERAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO EXPLAIN
OUR PROCESSES THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE. OUR
ESSENTIAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC. FOR THOSE OF YOU
FAMILIAR WITH THIS PROCESS WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE. WHILE
I GO THROUGH IT YET AGAIN FOR
THOSE WH MAY BE TUNING IN FOR
THE VERY FIRST TIME. I'M GONNA
COVER THE TECHNICAL SIDE OF
THINGS FOR TODAY. IN RESPONSE TO
THE COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
SENATORS AND SENATE STAFF WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
STATE AND LOCAL ORDERS THE
SENATE WILL BE HOLDING THIS
ESSENTIAL HEARING AND IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS BY
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO THIS HEARING ROOM
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WE'LL BE MAKING OUR WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THERE IS A
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
AN ACCESS CODE. IT'S POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND IT'S
GOING TO BE DISPLAYED RIGHT NOW
ON THE SCREEN. THE PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX THREE. THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN THREE SIX
TWO EIGHT THREE THREE. AND IT
WILL BE UP AGAIN A COUPLE MORE
TIMES DURING THE COURSE OF THE
HEARING. FOR THE BENEFIT OF
THOSE WATCHING AND TUNING IN.
WHEN WE DO MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENT A MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY. WILL
OPEN YOUR LAWN AND AT THAT TIME
YOU MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US
TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ANY FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU WERE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON. PRIOR TO GIVING YOUR
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU SO WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE IN
THIS. I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE MAYBE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE
TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS
IT IS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE
SOMELAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW ONLINE
TOOLS. SO PLEASE BE PATIENT SO
EVERYONE CAN BE HEARD AND ON
BEHALF OF OUR INCREDIBLE COURT
REPORTER I'M GOING TO ASK ALL
SPEAKERS COLLEAGUES IN WITNESSES
ALIKE TO SPEAK SLOWLY AND
CLEARLY. SO ARE BEFORE WE BEGIN
TODAY'S AGENDA WE NEED TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. AND ANOTHER
REMINDER TO MY COLLEAGUES WILL
NEED TO TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONES
FOR THE ROLL CALL AND EVERY TIME
THAT WE THOSE. AND WITH THAT-
MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ROATH KAMLAGER HERE
I'M LONGER HERE LAYERED HERE
THEY'RE HERE BATES HERE HE'S
HERE ATKINS HERE ATKINS HERE.
THANK YOU- COLLEAGUES- I'M GOING
TO GO TO GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES
NOT REQUIRED TO APPEAR THIS ITEM
TO SEE THROUGH G. AND THESE ARE
FOR MEMBERS OF THE ALFRED P.
ALQUIST SEISMIC SAFETY
COMMISSION. DO I NEED TO
SEPARATE ANY OF THOSE OUT. OKAY-
LET ME- LET ME JUST REPEAT
MYSELF AS OUR COLLEAGUE- COMES
IN WELCOME NO IT'S OKAY WE ARE
ON GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR ITEMS TO SEE
THROUGH G. A. N. THESE ARE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES TO THE
ALFORD II ALQUIST SEISMIC SAFETY
COMMISSION. DO WE NEED TO PULL
ANY OUT FOR- SEPARATE VOTE. NO
OKAY THAT'S WHAT I'VE HEARD FROM
OUR COLLEAGUES SO WITH THAT MAN
PROTECT MY WOULD MOVE- ITEMS TO
SEE THROUGH G. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ROVE GROVE I KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I
LAYERED ON WHERE'D I'D BATES ALL
RIGHT IT'S AYE ATKINS AYE ATKINS
FIVE FIVE TWO ZERO THANK YOU
THAT IS FIVE TWO ZERO I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON
ITEM THREE REFERENCE OF BILLS TO
COMMITTEES. SENATOR COM LONGER
MOVES- MADAM SECRETARY WE CALL
THE ROLL. GROWTH GROW BY
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER I LAYERED.
LAYERED I BATES. AYE BATES AYE
ATKINS HIGH A CONCISE FIVE TWO
ZERO FIVE TWO ZERO THAT IS OUT
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR. AND ITEM ONE A. IS
THE APPOINTMENT OF WILLIAM W.
LIU TO THE GAMBLING CONTROL
COMMISSION- MISTER LIU WELCOME.
I'D LIKE TO INVITE YOU TO
INTRODUCE YOURSELF ALONG WITH
ANYONE YOU WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE OR THAT MIGHT BE
WITH YOU. AND AFTER THOSE
INTRODUCTIONS YOU CAN GO AHEAD
AND MAKE ANY OPENING COMMENTS
THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO. MAKE AND
THEN AFTER THAT I WILL GO
STRAIGHT TO COLLEAGUES FOR
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
WELCOME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK. THERE WE CAN WE ARE GOING
TO TALK FOR A FEW MINUTES WE'LL
SEE IF THERE'S FEEDBACK. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM PROCAMP THE
MATTER HERE AND NUMBER. OKAY WE
ARE COMMISSIONER LOU WE ARE
HAVING A LITTLE BIT OF
DIFFICULTY SO GIVE ME A SECOND
LET'S SEE IF WE CAN. FIX THAT.
AS I LOOK TO OUR INCREDIBLE
STAFF. THERE REALLY IS NOTHING
WORSE THAN TRYING TO MAKE SOME
COMMENTS AND NOT EVEN BEING ABLE
TO UNDERSTAND YOUR SELF ON
FEEDBACK SO WILL. SEE IF WE CAN
FIGURE THIS OUT. YES SURE.
OKAY THAT. OKAY RIGHT.
SO RIGHT NOW SURE WE CAN AND NOT
COMMISSIONER LOU THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR PATIENCE LET'S GO AHEAD
AND TRY AGAIN AND SEE IF YOU ARE
ABLE TO TALK WITHOUT HEARING
FEEDBACK. THANK YOU VERY. A GOOD
AFTERNOON PROTECT I THINK WE ARE
COMMISSIONER I THINK WE'RE STILL
HAVING A FEW- PROBLEM SO WE'RE
GOING TO. BUT I KNEW MY SPEAKER
WOULD THAT HELP IF I MEAN MY
SPEAKER YEAH. THAT WOULD
STRUCTURE LEADS. YES BUT IF IT.
I DON'T LIKE WHEN OU CALL FOR
HELP THAT'S WHAT MAKES IT IS A
PLUS YEAH. FOR THEREFORE YOU
CAN'T YOU HEAR ME OK. MAYBE YOU
JUST NEED TO SPEAKER WELL YOU
HEARD ABOUT. VERY GOOD FOR. BUT
COMMISSIONER- SAYS SAY HELLO
AGAIN LET'S TRY THIS HELLO. WELL
THAT'S GOOD. WHY DON'T WE SEE IF
WE CAN CONTINUE AND- FORGIVE ME
THIS IS NOT THE KIND OF HEARING
COMMISSIONER WE TYPICALLY RUN.
SO HELLO WELCOME AND GO RIGHT
AHEAD OKAY THANK YOU- GOOD
AFTERNOON AND PRO TEM BACK ABOUT
AND- BY SHARE AGAIN AND MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE
YES I WANTED TO TAKE ITS TIME TO
FIX IT IN MY DISTINCT HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE TO SERVE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS
AND I AM DEEPLY GRATEFUL FOR
GOVERNOR NEWSOM FOR THIS
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE SERVING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WORKING ALONGSIDE MY-
COLLEAGUES ABOUT DIFFERENT
HEALTH COMMISSIONERS I THANK THE
MEMBER ROB AGAIN FOR- DOCTOR
DISCUSSION. I DEFINITELY WANT TO
THANK MY WIFE MARJORIE SHE'S ON
SHE'S MY BETTER HALF SHE TO
SUPPORT OF ALL MY ENDEAVORS FOR
THE PAST THIRTY SIX YEARS AND I
THINK SHE'S ONLINE- I'M WORK ON
THE OFFICE RIGHT NOW SHE'S
ONLINE- AT MY HOUSE I WANT TO
THANK EXTEND ON MY SON MARKETS
FROM HOUSTON TEXAS GO AND MY
DAUGHTER MARIAH THE NEW YORK AND
THEY SHOULD BE ONLINE FOR HELP
THEY DON'T WANT TO. I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK
COMMISSIONER SIGN EXECUTIVE
RECTOR MISLED BAXTER BAXTER AND
EXECUTIVE TEAM- ONBOARDING OF
THE ON THE TOPICS IN THE MEETING
BRIEFINGS FOR THE PAST FEW
MONTHS HAS BEEN REALLY- HELPFUL
AND- VERY. COMPELLING ADDITION
LIKE TO SET UP THANK DICKSON
RULES MEMBER- FOR THE TIME AND
WITH ME AND- QUEST ON THE SUB.
COM AT BEST PICTURE ONE I'M MUCH
TO BE MY OTHER. MEMBERS THAT- MY
- BERMAN MIGHT NOT ARE ONLINE
BUT THE ON HEALTH THEY ARE OF
THIS. LOW MY CELL. HI MY FAMILY
AND IMMIGRATED UNITED. ABOUT
FIFTY YEARS A- AND THEY CAME
FROM. TO UNITED STATES. MY PARA
OUT. WORKED. THEY BASICALLY
UPROOTED. THE CHANGER CALL STAND
OUT CAN OVER START OVER STAY ON
A SACRIFICE A LOT IN FACT. AND
MY FATHER AND MOTHER WERE ON MY
WORK FOR COST FOR MANY MY MOM
WERE FIRST ROEBUCK. FOR MANY
YEARS AND THEN THE COUPLE WHERE
DAIS MONEY AND STATE CALM WERE
ABLE TO PURSUE MY FATHER DREAM
OF PURCHASE A MULTI SO DAVID
BANNER MOTEL FOR. TWENTY PLUS
YEARS YEAH IT'S A VERY HIGH-
WORK- BEING AT SOME OF THE
PARTNER- BEING THERE FOR THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS AFTER
REALLY MIRED IN FOR THEIR WORK
ETHICS AND HARD AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S WHAT TO TRANSPIRE TO US.
MY SUPPLY. MY BACKGROUND WILL AT
MENTIONED IT YOU KNOW THIRTY
YEARS THIS SERVICE- I WORK FOR
STATE FOR THIRTY YEARS- IN THE
PAST AREAS OF AUDITING FINANCIAL
EXAMINATIONS AND PROGRAM
MANAGEMENT. THE CARD IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN- AND THEN IN
THAT TIME I'VE BEEN SERVING TO
THOSE OF OTHERS SOME NONPROFIT
CONTRACT MALARIA. GEN IN ABOUT
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN- BY CLYDE
AND NOT NOT APPOINTED TO THE
COMMISSION SCHEME POLICY
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. AND BEEN
SITTING THERE FOR FOUR YEARS-
AND THAT TIME IS ON A LOT ABOUT
THE CAR MINISTRY UNDERSTANDING
THEIR CONCERNS AS WELL AS THE
BUREAU'S GAMBLING CONTROL
CONCERNS- AND THEN THE OFFICE OF
PROBLEM GAMBLING. TURN TO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE. AFTER FOUR
YEARS I CAN LOOK AT AND SEE THAT
I WANT TO CONTINUE- IN THE
PROCESS- INDIC COMMISSIONS ALL
COMMISSIONERS AND- PROVIDING MY
FINANCIAL EXPERTISE AND THAT. SO
THAT'S WHY I SEE DIDN'T- EARLY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- FOR
DISAPPOINTMENT. A. I. I LIKE MY
PARENTS ON A SOFTIE STYLE
PURSUED HER DREAM TO WHAT THEY
WANT AND MY WIFE AND I ALWAYS
TELL OUR KIDS TO PURSUE
SOMETHING THAT'S CHALLENGER SIX
THING THAT'S CHALLENGING FOR
FILLING OUT THEIR JOBS ANDTHEY
HAVE DONE THAT AND I THINK THIS
PARTICULAR OPPORTUNITY CAME
AROUND AND I DIDN'T. WANT TO-
HAVE REGRETS OF NOT PURSUING IT
AND NOT SEEKING IT SO THE WORSE
COME TO WORSE IS THE GOVERNOR
OFFICE SAID NO AND WORSE COME TO
WORSE IS THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE WAS STATE NO. BUT I
HOPE I GET OUR SUPPORT. I
REALLY ENJOYED YOU MAY. WORKING
WITH MY CALL- AT THE COMMISSION.
THE FIVE DIFFERENT DISCIPLINES
IT'S BEEN REALLY- MINE AS FAR
AS- DISCUSSIONS WE HAD OPEN
MINDED DISCUSSIONS AND VERY GOOD
DIALOGUE THE DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS OF LEGAL GOVERNMENT.
FIND OUT FINANCIALS LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE PUBLIC AT
LARGE OF THE FIVE OF US KIND OF
BRING A DIFFERENT EXPERTISE AND
HIGHS AND POINTS. SO I REALLY
ENJOYED MY COMMISSION I HOPE TO
CONTINUE IN THAT CAPACITY SO I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE- AND I HOPE THAT
INTO THIS HEARING DATE THAT
WOULD HAVE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU FOR MUCH MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU COMMISSIONER LOU- CENTER
LAYERED WOULD YOU LIKE TO START
US OFF THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELL
LET ME JUST SAY THAT. THIS IS
THE BANKING OR FINANCE SEAT THEN
DO YOU HAVE A DEGREE. IN
ACCOUNTING AND BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION AND LONG
EXPERIENCE SEEMS VALIDATED SO
I'M GONNA BE A COMFORTABLE
SUPPORTING YOU AND I HAVE NO
QUESTIONS ARE GLAD YOU'RE HERE
TODAY. THANK YOU SENATOR GLARED
AND THAT IS ALSO ON COMMON
COMMISSIONER LOU. SO- MUCH. LET
ME LET ME ASK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BAKERSFIELD- SENATOR GROVE IF
SHE WOULD LIKE TO GO NEXT THANK
YOU M. I WILL BRIEFLY ECHO MY
COMMENTS THAT ARE THE COMMENTS
THAT TO THEM MY COLLEAGUE MADE
HIS THE FORMER SECRETARY BUT- I
DID LOOK AT YOUR BACKGROUND
YOU'RE VERY QUALIFIED I DO HAVE
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS THAT I
JUST LIKE TO ASK JUST FOR ME.
YOUR INPUT AND I WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT I THINK YOUR STORY IS
INCREDIBLE THAT THE STORY COMING
YOUR PARENTS COMING FROM TAIWAN
WHAT YOU'VE DONE AND SERVING THE
STATE ALL THESE YEARS- JUST THE
BACKGROUND THAT YOU HAVE YOUR
NONPROFIT THAT YOU TRULY ARE
THAT IT CALIFORNIA DREAM THE
AMERICAN DREAM SO THANK YOU FOR.
A SERVING IN THIS CAPACITY- I DO
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
REGARDING TECHNOLOGY AND THE
TECHNOLOGY CHANGE AND HOW DOES
THE COMMISSION WORK TO ENSURE
THAT GAMBLING REGULATIONS EVOLVE
TO MATCH THE EVER CHANGING NEEDS
OF THE INDUSTRY MISSION CARD
ROOMS EARLIER I'M- JUST CURIOUS
- BY. FAR AS- THE COMMISSION
SHALL WE- KIND OF TOOK A LEAD AS
FAR AS EARLY ON- BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC WORRIES. START LOOKING
INTO A TECHNOLOGY ITSELF- AS FAR
AS TO- SECURITY AND PORTABILITY
AS FAR AS LAPTOP AND SO FOR.
SOME INDEPENDENT MAKE. OCCURRED
AND WE WERE ALL PRETTY MUCH
READY TO GO. SO I THINK THAT THE
COMMISSION ITSELF IS PRETTY.
TOUGH FOR THINKING. NOW COMING
TO THE COURT ROOM JOHN YOU. HAVE
AREAS LEVELS- FONG. AS FAR AS
SIZE OF. SO THAT WE HAVE TO KIND
OF LOOK AT AND REVIEW ON THE
FIRST LIKE TO WE DID THE- JEEP
HOW CAN POLICY ADVISER. THE
PROJECT ON SERBIA. SO THAT IS
SOMETHING TECHNOLOGY THAT- YOU
KNOW WE WANT TO HAVE BETTER
TECHNOLOGY DIVERSITY GET DOWN
HIGH. AND HAVING ALSO- OF WHERE
TO PLACE IN THE OF THE CAMERAS
AND SO FORTH. SO X. WAS A
SECURITY. MONITOR AND ALL THAT.
WHICH IS BEFORE THAT WERE THE
DEATH SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO
ASK ME. WORKING LOCKHEED TO GAIN
ADVISORY INDUSTRY. TO KIND OF. A
PUSH FORWARD IN THAT AREA A
SECURITY IDEA INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY LIKE CONVENTION.
SQUARE IS THAT. IS THAT- THE
IT'S VERY RIGHT NOW YOU HAVE A
LOT OF- SECURITY AS FAR AS
BRIDGES AND HOPEFULLY THAT
INDUSTRY WOULD TAKE IT TO A LOT
OF THE SMALLER CAR ROOMS. MAY
NOT HAVE THAT KIND OF
CERTIFICATIONS BUT I THINK THEY
ARE LOOKING MORE WHERE IT. YEAH
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH INDEED
BECAUSE YOU DID BRING UP THE
PANDEMIC I WAS CURIOUS I KNOW
THAT CARD ROOMS WERE CONSIDER
ESSENTIAL PEOPLE RIGHT THERE. DO
YOU SEE RECOVERY HAPPENING NOW
OR WHAT'S YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
RECOVERY FOR THE GAMING
INDUSTRY- BECAUSE OF THE PAIN
THE RESPONSE TO THE PANDEMIC. L.
AS FAR AS- OSTS STABBING OF THE
CAR ROOMS THAT'S LICENSING- FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE. MONTHS I'VE BEEN
THERE I HAVE NOT SEEN ANY
DECREASES- MY- FINDERS- NUMBER
OF PAGES. HAS NOT DIMINISHED- I
SEE THE APPLICANTS COMING
THROUGH EITHER RENEW OR NEW
LICENSE A LICENSE COMING
THROUGH. SO I HAVEN'T SEEN IT
DIMINISH OF THAT AREA ABSORBERS.
THE CARD MYSELF THE DEALERS
EXCEPT TRUCK- I I'M NOT TOO SURE
WHERE THERE'S LIKE IN THE AREAS
OF THE HOME. SUPPORT KITCHEN IN
THAT PERIOD THERE'S OTHER AREAS
LIKE HOTELS AND THINGS LIKE THAT
IT TEARS UP THEIR CASINOS ACT
LARGE- BUT HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING
ABOUT THAT. DIMINISH THE CARGO
OKAY THANK YOU. SIR I LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING YOU. MUCH
IS THANK YOU CENTER GROWTH IS
COM LONGER. THANK YOU MADAM TEMP
I TO- BELIEVE YOU TO BE
QUALIFIED FOR THIS POSITION AND-
IT REALLY ONLY HAVE ONE QUESTION
WHICH IS- YOUR THOUGHTS ON AS WE
MOVE FORWARD IN THIS- EVER
CHANGING WORLD OF OURS AS IT
RELATES TO GAMBLING. IN CURRENCY
WHERE YOU THINK DIGITAL
CURRENCY. OUT WILL BEGIN TO PLAY
A ROLE IN- GAMBLING
ESTABLISHMENTS- AND- ACTIVITIES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
YOUR ROLE IN THAT. WELL RIGHT
NOW YOU KNOW LIKE
CRYPTOCURRENCY- IS NOT LEGAL
BECAUSE IT'S NOT BEEN- MY
STANDING RECOGNIZER IS NOT A CAN
OF. RECOGNIZE CURRENCY SO AND
THEN NOT SENSE IS NOT IN THE CAR
I HAVE NOT SEEN ANYTHING HAS
COME THROUGH- SENATOR AS FAR AS
IN YOUR FINANCIALS REPORTS OF
CURRENCIES. SO I AND- I'M SURE
IN INS DOWN THE LINE WE HAVE TO
A TRUSTED- BUT RIGHT NOW YOU
KNOW IT IS SIX EIGHT- NOT LEGAL.
TO HAVE THAT INTERACTION
INTERTWINED OF THE FUNDS OF
INTERMINGLED THE. FUNDS WITH
CASH ITSELF. THE DAY IS TRUE
THIS GIVEN THE FACT THAT- EIGHT
WELL LET LOTS OF FOLKS ARE
INTERESTED IN IT AND I GUESS YOU
KNOW FEDERALLY THERE'S BEEN A-
REQUEST TO KIND OF- THIRTY EIGHT
AND- DISFIGURING ALL KINDS O
THINGS HAPPEN IN THESE CARD
ROOMS WANTED JUST TO KNOW YOUR
THOUGHTS BUT- THIS IS. DOWN THE
LINE I AM SURE- I HAVE NO OTHER
QUESTIONS FOR YOU AND LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING YOU WHEN
THE CONFIRMATION COMES UP. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR THANK YOU
SENATOR KAMLAGER MADAM VICE
CHAIR. THANK YOU I HAD TO STEP
OUT FOR A MINUTE MISTER LIU SO
I'M NOT SURE OF. MY QUESTIONS
ARE ALREADY AT HALF THE IF SO
YOU CAN- CERTAINLY MENTION THAT
BUT I THINK IN YOUR- GOALS HERE
ONE THAT FELT REALLY JUMPS OFF
THE PAGE AND SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE ALL VERY CONCERNED WITH
THIS- TO FURTHER ADVANCE
CALIFORNIA AS A NATIONAL LEADER
IN GAMBLING REGULATION. WHILE
MAINTAINING STRONG PUBLIC TRUST
I THINK THE CONCERN HAS BEEN
ABOUT THE CRIMINAL ELEMENT
GETTING IN AND- BEING ABLE TO
CHANGE THEIR OPERATIONS ON ON A
MOMENT'S NOTICE. AND ALSO THE
QUESTION IS HOW WILL THE
REGULATIONS BE WRITTEN. THAT
THEY WILL COVER THE EVER
CHANGING OF MONEY LAUNDERING
WORLD KNOWING THAT MONEY
LAUNDERING AS BEYOND A- BIT OF.
BIT OF AN ISSUE PROBABLY A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE IN TERMS OF
ALL THE TRUST. THAT'S THERE SO
IF YOU COULD ELABORATE A LITTLE
BIT ON THAT. ON THAT WOULD BE I
THINK IMPORTANT TO HEAR. I THANK
YOUNG MONEY LEARNING LIKE YOU
MENTIONED THIS- DISPATCHER
IMPORTANT YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO
MAINTAIN THE INTEGRITY OF
ACCOUNT CALIFORNIA CARBON.
INDUSTRY WORKING GAMING INDUSTRY
PERIOD. AND I THINK IT'S- EFFORT
MONEY LAUNDERING. WE WILL. YEAH
THERE'S A THERE'S A- ENTITY-
CARBON DENSIFIED- WITH MONEY
LAUNDERING THE YOU KNOW THAT WE
AS THE COMMISSIONERS COURT
CONDITIONS ON IT ON RENEWALS.
AND IF YOU'RE A WILL EVALUATE OR
DOING YOUR DESTINATION WHEN YOU.
TAKE MORE SCRUTINY OF THAT
NATURE- ON THE NEW PART. SO WE
TRIED TO AND FINALLY MY MARKET
BEGAN FIRING ON. AND CONTINUE
MONITORING THAT WE MIGHT HAVE
ADDITIONAL. REQUIREMENTS
CONDITIONS AT THREE YOU KNOW
RECORDING REQUIREMENTS OR
CONSULTING- THE VALUATION AND
EVALUATIONS REQUIREMENTS. BUT AS
FAR AND SO THAT'S ONE AREA. THE
OTHER AREA IS MATIC YOU
MENTIONED THE TRANSACTION
RODRIGUEZ TOWARDS. THAT POINT. I
BELIEVE IT LOOKS THE KIND. BUT I
HAVE NOTS IT- I UNDERSTAND IS
THAT PACKAGE GOING A FINE STAGE
REVIEW INTO BY. THE STAFF AND WE
SEE THAT LATER ON THIS YEAR AND
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. SURE WHAT
TIME LATER ON THIS YEAR SO- SHE
DID THAT HER HOPEFULLY THAT WILL
CAPTURE A LOT OF THE THINGS
THAT. YOU HAVE SUCH A- DRESS A
CONCERN AND WE GET CAPTURED AT
IN THE TAKE THAT YOUR CONCERN IN
OUR DELIBERATIONS AND
DISCUSSIONS. WHEN THAT PACKAGE
JUST DOES COME UP. THANK YOU
THAT THAT ANSWERED ACTUALLY A
SECOND OF THAT QUESTION SO THANK
YOU I WONDERED WHAT THE STATUS
WAS. THE WILL BE LOOKING FORWARD
TO CALL FOR THOSE SO THAT. THIS
WILL NO LONGER KIND OF. BE A
QUESTION OF KNOWLEDGE CERTAINLY
OF THE LEGISLATURE AND OR OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND THE PUBLIC.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE ON AND YOU WILL HAVE MY
SUPPORT WHEN WE ARE READY TO
VOTE ON. YOUR NOMINATION THANK
YOU. SENATE DEBATE WAS. THANK
YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR AND- I
REALLY DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO
ADD OTHER THAN WHAT MY COMMENTS
HAVE ARE MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID
RELATED THEIR COMMENTS ABOUT
YOUR LONG HISTORY OF SERVICE SO
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTIONS YOU
DIDN'T ANSWER I AM GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND MOVE TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO MAY WISH TO COMMENT
AND I'M GONNA HAVE PUT BACK UP
ON THE SCREEN THAT- PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX
THREE THE ACCESS CODE SEVEN
THREE SIX TWO EIGHT THREE THREE
BUT WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN HERE
WITH WITNESSES IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE IN SUPPORT- I DO
NOT SEE ANYONE HERE FROM THE
PUBLIC IN THE TO SPEAK- SO I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD AND GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE- AND- LET'S
SEE MODERATOR WELCOME YOU TO THE
CONVERSATION. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
WHILE WE ARE WAITING ON PEOPLE
TO QUEUE UP FROM MISTER
MODERATOR. LET ME REMIND
WITNESSES THAT WE AND WHEN YOU
SPEAK PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION OF ANY AND THE
POSITION ON THE APPOINTMENT AND
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF OUR COURT
REPORTER SPEAK SLOWLY AND
CLEARLY. MISTER MODERATOR BACK
TO YOU. I HAVE NO LINES AT THIS
TIME. OKAY WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL BE BORROWED BACK WITH
YOU I'M SURE- HAVING HEARD ARE
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR
FROM WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. I
WILL NOW GO TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AND AGAIN THERE IS NO
ONE HERE PHYSICALLY IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. SO MISTER
MODERATOR I'M GONNA COME BACK TO
YOU FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO MAY WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO
POINT OF TIME. WE HAVE NO LINES
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU WELL
COMMISSIONER LOW THIS MAY HAVE
BEEN THE QUICKEST TO- BUT I
GUARANTEE YOU IT IS NOT A
REFLECTION ON. ITS REFLECTION ON
YOU POSITIVELY- AS OPPOSED TO
ANYTHING ELSE SO I SEE THAT
SENATOR LAYERED ALREADY HAS HIS
LIGHT. ON TO MAKE A MOTION I
WOULD MOVE THE CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU- MADAM SECRETARY WE
CALL OUR ROLE. ROATH RO I
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER I LAYERED
LAYERED HI BATES HI BATES AYE
ATKINS HI HOW CAN SIGN FIVE ZERO
THAT WAS FIVE TWO ZERO UNANIMOUS
WE WILL MOVE YOUR- CONFIRMATION
ONTO THE SENATE FLOOR WITH OUR
CONGRATULATIONS COMMISSIONER.
THAT'S OPPORTUNITY INTO SERVICE.
THANK YOU. ARE VERY MUCH AGAIN
HAVE A GOOD REST OF YOUR DAY
THANK YOU. I THANK ARE LOOKING
AT OUR COURT REPORTER THAT WE
MAY BE ABLE TO CONTINUE OKAY.
THAT'S WONDERFUL NEWS LET ME SEE
IF OUR ITEM ONE B. OUR NEXT-
APPOINTEE IS WITH US YES- SO THE
NEXT GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE
REQUIRED TO APPEAR WILL BE THE
APPOINTMENT OF NICOL S. MORGAN
TO THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD. AND MS MORGAN LET
ME WELCOME YOU AND OFFER YOU THE
SAME OPPORTUNITY TO INTRODUCE
TECHNOLOGY ANYONE YOU WOULD LIKE
TO THAT I IS WITH YOU OR THAT
THAT YOU WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE GO
AHEAD AND MAKE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
AND THEN WILL GO RIGHT TO OUR
COLLEAGUESFOR QUITE FOR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS WELCOME.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON DOWN
HER TENANTS SENATORS IS TRULY AN
HONOR TO HAVE BEEN APPOINTED BY
GOVERNOR NEWSOM ANSWER CARE
BEFORE YOU TODAY. I AM HERE WITH
MY MOTHER BEVERLY A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER CELEBRATING
NINETEEN YEARS OF BUSINESS HERE
IN SACRAMENTO. MY STEPFATHER
CAN'T HE WAS RETIRED AND THAT
SHRINK AND MY SON XAVIER AND
ENERGETIC KINDERGARTNER WHO.
LOVES TO CONTAX SCIENCE
PROJECTS. MARQUAM HAS BEEN A
PASSION OF FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS NOW WHEN I LOOK BACK MY
INTEREST IN A WIDER BEGAN IN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL WHEN I FIRST
LEARNED OF THE WATER CYCLE.
INTEREST CONTINUES TO GROW
THROUGHOUT HIGH SCHOOL AND
BECAME A PASSION IN COLLEGE WHEN
I DECIDE TO BECOME A CIVIL
ENGINEER. WITH A FOCUS ON WATER
QUALITY. EARLY IN MY CAREER AND
MADE A DECISION TO WORK IN BOTH
THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTORS.
TO LEARN FROM EACH YEAR POINT
OUT POLICIES AND REGULATIONS ARE
DEVELOPED. AND HOW THEY ARE
IMPLEMENTED AND COMPLIED WITH. I
WAS FORTUNATE TO LEARN HOW TO
DESIGN DRINKING WATER WASTEWATER
AND RECYCLED WATER FACILITIES. I
HAVE ALSO HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
VOLUNTEERING AS A BOARD MEMBER
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA WATER
ENVIRONMENT ASSOCIATION WHERE MY
DUTIES INCLUDE PROVIDING
TRAINING AND DISSEMINATING
INFORMATION. CHANNEL WATER
WASTEWATER COMMUNITY ON VARIOUS
TECHNICAL AREAS POLICIES AND
REGULATIONS. IN ADDITION TO
REPRESENTING THE WAS WORKING
VIDAK LOCALLY AND NATIONALLY.
SINCE JOINING THE WATER COURTS I
HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND MY
KNOWLEDGE ON WATER QUALITY
ANSWERING YOUR WATER AND GAIN
KNOWLEDGE OF THE WATER RIGHT
SYSTEM AND OF THE DIVISION OF
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE. AT THE
YEAR PRIOR TO BECOMING AN
APPOINTMENT TO THE BOARD I HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF SERVING AS A
MEMBER OF THE WHITE BOARDS
RACIAL EQUITY WORKING GROUP. IN
THE PAST EIGHT MONTHS I HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO USE MY BACKGROUND
AND EXPERIENCE WITH. IN MY ROLE
AS A BOARD MEMBER TO LISTEN TO
THE PERSPECTIVES AND CONCERNS OF
ALL THE COMMUNITIES. THE STATE
BOARD SERVERS. TO BRING THOSE
PERSPECTIVES AND INSIGHTS TO THE
DISCUSSIONS. ASIAN MAKING
PROCESS TO SUPPORT THE WATER
BORDERS WERE EQUITY EMISSIONS AT
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT STEM
PROGRAMS. M. PASSIONATE ABOUT
DIVERSIFYING THE STEM WORKFORCE
ADDED MR FIND WATER. THE WORLD
OF WATER. I ALSO USE MY
BACKGROUND TO UNDERSTAND THE
TECHNICAL AND SOCIAL IMPACTS OF
THE BOARD'S ACTIONS AND TO HELP
THE WORK ON A GLOBAL SOLUTIONS
IN THIS TIME TO CHANGE THANK YOU
I AM HAPPY TO ANSWERING
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET ME- START MADAM VICE CHAIR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO KICK US OFF
THE STOCK YOU. YES WELL THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE I SEE
YOU'VE BEEN ON THE WATER BOARD
AND IT HAS NOT ALWAYS BEEN AN
EASY BOARD TO SURVIVE I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF CONTROVERSY
THAT IS DEVELOPED OVER THE YEARS
ON SOME OF THE WATER BOARD
REGULATIONS THAT HAVE COME DOWN
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT. BUT I KNOW
THAT TO LISTENING TO YOUR
BACKGROUND BOB YOU ARE VERY
ENGAGED IN NOT ENSURING THAT WE
DO HAVE SUSTAINABLE WATER
RESOURCES IN OUR STATE- ONE OF
OTHER TO. MEANT TO PROJECT.
APPROACHES THAT HAVE BEEN VERY-
BENEFICIAL IN ALL MY DISTRICT
DIED THE POLICE TO FIND. THE
CELL PLANT IN- CARLSBAD. IN AN
ORANGE COUNTY WE HAVE THE ON.
THE GROUND WATER OFFERS IN FACT
I THINK ORANGE COUNTY HAS BEEN
THE LEADER IN THE USE OF
RECYCLED WATER TO REPLENISH OF
THE AQUIFER'S. SCHOOL OF MAYBE
YOU COULD GIVE ME KIND OF YOUR
IDEA ON THOSE TWO APPROACHES TO
WATER SUSTAINABILITY- AND- WHAT
YOU SEE. IN TERMS OF THE PROS
AND THE CONS THAT DEVELOP OVER
THEM AND WHERE YOU FROM WHERE
YOU LAND ON THAT CONTINUUM OF
BEING IN FAVOR OF- AND IF SO-
AND WE'RE NOT IN FAVOR OTHER.
YOU KNOW. WHAT WHAT ARE THE
ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED
SO WE CAN MAKE THOSE TWO
APPROACHES MAY BE. MORE POPULAR
KNOWING THAT ISRAEL AT WHAT IS
IT 55% OF THE WATER COMES FROM
DIESEL PLANTS. SO WE NEED TO BE
LOOKING AT SOMETHING AS WE LOOK
AT THE LONG DROUGHT PERIODS THAT
WE HAVE ENOUGH. CERTAINLY THE
CLIMATE CHANGE THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING SOME JUST SOME KIND
OF ELABORATE ON ON IN THOSE
AREAS THAT WOULD BE A VERY
HELPFUL TO ME AS I APPROACH SOME
OF. THE CONTROVERSY THAT
CONTINUES TO EXIST IN MY
DISTRICT. YES THEY YOU FOR THAT
. YES DEFINITELY WE NEED TO TAKE
A LOOK AT EACH AREA- AND- LOOK
AT WHAT APPROACH WORKS BEST FOR
THAT NOW AREA. AROUND YOUR BOTH
LOCALLY- ON AND REGIONALLY THE
GOVERNOR HAS ENCOURAGE
MANAGEMENT TO DROP AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. BASED ON LOCAL
CONDITIONERS. WELL CONDITION
WHILE THE GOVERNOR EXPANDED THE
DROUGHT PROCLAMATION STATEWIDE
ON OCTOBER NINETEENTH NUMEROUS
COUNTIES HAD ALREADY DECLARED A
LOCAL DROUGHT IN SUMMER WATCHES
HAVE BEGUN IMPLEMENTING MATH
MANDATORY CONSERVATION MEASURES
MESSRS. MANY YEARS JUST ASK YOU-
JUST PRODUCT DISCUSSED IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN
DOING A GREAT JOB OF
DIVERSIFYING MY PORTFOLIO AND
SOME WITH SOME ARE REALLY TRULY
LEADERS IN THIS AREA FOR
EXAMPLE. NEVER MIND- I JUST HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WEEKS AGO
IT'S REYES- THIS IS A WIDER TO
TORRENT OF WATER REPLACEMENT
DISTRICTS AT SEVEN CALIFORNIA'S.
ROLE SINCE HER FOR WATER
RECYCLING AND ENVIRONMENTAL
LEARNING THIS PROJECT WAS PART
OF THE WIDER ANYTHING IT'S NOW.
ALSO KNOWN AS WENT PROGRAM.
THREE BROWN LARSON HI. PRIOR TO
THE PROJECT UNDERSTAND WHERE OUR
DEMAND THE LOCAL STUFF. WAS THE
COMPLETE OF THE PROJECT PROVIDE
LOCAL. WATER SUPPLY PROGRAM
REPLENISHMENT THE MONTH HELP FOR
WORKING. IT WAS JUST MANY
THERE'S A WHY I'M OF MANY PARTS
COMPLETED ON THIS PROGRAM. IT
HELPS OUR- TO INCREASE LOCAL THE
STATE BUILDING WATER. I'D PART
OF THE PROGRAM IS ONE FOR. OF
YOUR D. ALONG WITH A BY ANGELES
APARTMENT FIRE POWER. WATER IN
POWER IN METROPOLITAN WATER OF
SAN CAL BURKE CLASS. ON THIS
EFFORT TO INCREASE THIS LOCALS
WHAT TIME SAID HELLO. AND THIS
IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
CONTINUE TO DO AND MODEL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO THAT WE
CAN BE MORE RECENTLY. AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. IT'S SO YOU KNOW JUST
LOOKING AT THE PICTURE. YOU ON
JANUARY FOURTH THE STATE FOR THE
TOP EMERGENCY CONSERVATION
REGULATIONS THAT PROHIBIT
CERTAIN WASTEFUL WATER USE
PRACTICES. THESE ACTIONS ARE LOW
COST EASY IS IT WILL BE IN SAME
VIRUS AWARENESS. THIS
REGULATIONS ONCE I FACT ON
JANUARY EIGHTEENTH WE'RE NOW
SEEING GROWING RESPONSIBLE WATER
SYSTEMS AND HOW LAKE. WATER
SYSTEMS ARE SPAMMY TALKING THEIR
OWN ORDINANCES ANYWAYS WHY
PRACTICES IN THE STATE SAN JUAN
MORE. WANT MORE REPORTS WATER
RATES IN JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
TWO YEAR EVER RECORDED IN
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN
JANUARY. TWENTY TWENTY COMBINED
. HE THESE PROJECTS THERE AND
REGIONAL. ALONG WITH THE
INCREASE IN SAVINGS THAT WE SAW
IN PEACE ENCOURAGE SIZE OF THE
MARKETING REGULATIONS ARE
PROMPTING. SHIFT THE MINDSET
AWARENESS THAT CAN HELP THE
STATE'S ASSESSMENT RESPONSE
ONGOING DROUGHT CONDITIONS THIS
IS A GOVERNOR'S CALL. WHEN THE
STATE'S ABOUT AMERICA'S WATER
USED. BY FIFTEEN THE SACRED ONE
PM TO SAVINGS OF SEVEN POINT 4%
DECEMBER WHEN THE STATE WIDE
SERVING SAVINGS ALSO REACHED
SIXTEEN POINT 2% THE STATE BOARD
HAVE PLAN TO PRESENT ENOUGH
YOUNGER WATER CONSERVATION
DURING HIS FIRST MARCH FIRST
BOARD MEETING OUR BECAUSE OUR
WATER SUPPLIES HAD INTEL
FEBRUARY TWENTY EIGHTH TO REPORT
THURSDAY HAS. A COMPLETE DATASET
WAS NOT YET AVAILABLE RATHER
THAN RELEASING PROVISIONAL DATA
THAT WE STAND NEEDS TO BE
REVISED WE WILL BE SHARING THE
JANUARY AT THEIR NEXT REGULARLY.
SCHEDULED BOARD MEETING ON MARCH
FIFTEENTH. I MUSTN'T HOW CAN DO
REMAIN VERY. HE IS STILL
CRITICAL FOR. ALL DO WHAT THEY
CAN TO SAVE WATER ESPECIALLY
OUTDOORS. I DO UNDERSTAND THAT
REGULATIONS ARE NEEDED CERTAINLY
ON THE CONSERVATION SIDE THAT I
THINK INCENTIVES ARE NEEDED FOR
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PURSUE
THESE PROJECTS THAT WE KNOW- DO
WORK- DIESEL AND JOB GROUNDWATER
REPLENISHMENT VERY IMPORTANT
VERY EXPENSIVE. SO I THINK THE
INCENTIVE CAN COME FROM THE
WATER BOARD GETTING BEHIND THOSE
WITH A LITTLE MORE POSITIVE
STATEMENT AND ALSO SUPPORTING
OUR FUNDING WOULD WE HAVE I
THINK ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
FOR WATER RESILIENCY AND- THAT
MANY I THINK CALL IT REALLY
NEEDS TO BE INCENTIVIZE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHO ARE. CONSIDERING
ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT
APPROACHES ON BECAUSE IT LOOKS
LIKE THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO BE OF. A COUPLE OF
DECADES BUT THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR SERVICE AND A LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING WHAT HAPPENS AS WE GO
FORWARD AND WE'RE ALL PRAYING
FOR MORE RAIN. THANKS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR
SENATOR COME LONGER LET ME ASK
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO. GO NEXT
SURE THANK YOU FOR THAT MATTER
I'M PRO TEM SO- THANK YOU I AM.
TO SEE THAT YOU HAVE EXTENSIVE
BACKGROUND AS A CIVIL ENGINEER
AND- JUST WANTED TO KNOW YOUR IF
YOU COULD SHARE WITH US ON HOW
YOUR EXPERIENCE AS A CIVIL
ENGINEER YOU KNOW HAS INFORMED
THE WORK THAT YOU- WE'LL BE
DOING. ON THIS PARTICULAR BOARD
BECAUSE ICE I BELIEVE GIVEN THE
CONVERSATIONS WE ARE ALL
INVOLVED IN AND AROUND. NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND CONSERVATION
AND WAYS THAT WE CAN SHORE UP
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE AND BE
INNOVATIVE AND CAPACITY I WOULD
ASSUME THAT THOSE THINGS- ARE
THINGS THAT YOU WOULD BE ABLE TO
. DEEPLY UNDERSTAND AND HELP
INFORM AND SHAPE IN DISCUSSIONS
ON THE BOARD BUT THAT COULD BE
JUST ME BUT SO I WAS WONDERING
IF MAYBE YOU COULD SHARE A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT- YOUR WORK AS A
CIVIL ENGINEER. AND IT'S
COMPATIBILITY WITH THIS
PARTICULAR BOARD. YES AND SO YOU
KNOW I EIGHT. I WOULD USE MY
BROAD PERSPECTIVE MIGHT MIGHT
RIGHT TECHNICAL BACKGROUND TO
BRING TO THE DISCUSSIONS TO
UNDER STAND THAT- TO TENDER
STANDS THOSE TECHNICAL PIECES OF
THE DECISION MAKING THAT THAT
THOSE DECISIONS THAT COME IN
FRONT OF US I SOMETIMES USE THAT
TO BE A ONE CALL IT TECHNICAL
TRANSLATOR. TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS THE
TECHNICAL ASPECTS OF THOSE
ISSUES THAT COME BEFORE I ALSO-
AS OC BECAUSE HE WANTS TO HELP
DEMYSTIFY WATER IN SO THAT WHEN
I AM OUT WITH ENGINEERING. THESE
TO. NOW THAT COVERAGE BUT ALSO
HELP WHICH YOU THE JUNIOR OR THE
COURT RIGHT WHAT WE WE'RE HAPPY
A CALL. IF WITH SOMEONE WHO
ISN'T NOT ALSO THAT TIME BACK.
TO BRING THAT TO THE- ABOUT. IN
THE FUTURE AFTER MOVING FORWARD
WHETHER IT'S THIS IS THAT THIS
DECISION A WE'RE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON THROUGH OR IT'S A
FUTURE DECISION SO THAT
COMMUNITIES CAN HELP ADVOCATE
FOR THEMSELVES. I HAVE A DUTY TO
MEET WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND
COMMUNITIES TO UNDERSTAND THIS
BIGGER PICTURE IN NOT JUST THE
TECHNICAL ASPECTS THAT I'M
RETURNING TO THE TABLE THAT
WEREN'T. ADDITIONAL TESTING
TECHNICAL ASPECTS AND ALSO
LISTEN TO- THE COMMUNITIES TO
UNDERSTAND THE OTHER PIECES THAT
ARE EIGHT FEET THE SOCIAL
IMPACTS THE OTHER ECONOMIC
IMPACTS TO BRING. ALL OF THAT TO
THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS SO.
TO EXPAND FROM JUST BEING- WHO
DECIDE. OF THIS ALWAYS TO AND IN
WHO UNDER THE TECH PIECE AND
ALSO. EVERYTHING OUT THAT NEED
TO BE INCORPORATED TO AN IT. THE
GREAT YOU FOR THAT AND WHEN WE
TALKED YESTERDAY- AND I'M
QUOTING YOU OU SAID THAT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
DOING SOME AMAZING WORK. IN THE-
AREA OF CONSERVATION IN IN YOUR-
EARLIER COMMENTS YOU REFERENCED
THE TOUR- THAT YOU TOOK IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SO GIVEN
THAT OF COURSE I REPRESENTS THAT
PART OF THE STATE WAS JUST
WONDERING IF YOU COULD SHARE.
ANY LESSONS LEARNED EITHER FROM
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING IN LA OR-
THROUGH LED W. P. THAT COULD BE
APPLIED TO OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE AS WE TACKLE THE ISSUES OF
CONSERVATION AND WATER
RECLAMATION. MADAM ARE SENATOR
CAN I ADD SAN DIEGO TO THAT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND THAT WAY
I DON'T THINK THAT'S RIGHT ASK
THE SEVEN CALIFORNIA THE AMAZING
WORK IN SAN DIEGO AND IN LOS
ANGELES. ANY MAYES SAID IN A
REVERSE. CAL WELL WE'RE GOING TO
BE ALL INCLUSIVE TODAY THANK YOU
SENATOR. YASIN SO IN MY PREVIOUS
WHEN I WAS REFERRING TO SOME THE
SEVERAL SOME THE SEVERAL JUST
YOU THIS THAT HAVE BEEN-
MANDATORY CONSERVE. MEASURES
YEAH YUP SAN DIEGO IS OF THOSE
AND MANY AND START OTHERS DOWN
HEALTH. STATE CONTINUE TO
IMPLEMENT THERE ARE SOME OF OUR
MANDATORY CONSERVATION MEASURES.
FROM THE LAST ROUND THEY DIDN'T
STOP IMPLEMENTING- SOME OF THOSE
MEASURE THAT NEED TO OF THOSE
MEASURE. PART OF THIS EVERYDAY
LIFE IT MAY COST A WAY OF LIFE
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO DO
THROUGH OUT THE STATE IS MAKE
CONSERVATION A WAY OF LIFE. AND
THEY THEY DID THAT WE WANT TO
LEARN FROM THESE EXAMPLES AND
SPREAD THAT INFORMATION AND YOU
SHARE IT THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SO THAT WE- ASK WHAT WE'RE WE'RE
INDUSTRY WEEK WE'RE ACT REACTING
TO IT AND YES- YEAH. YES WE DO
NEED TO MAKE THOSE INVESTMENTS
THERE ARE INVESTMENTS- BEING.
YOUR THERE WERE SOME HAS.
INVESTMENT MADE LAST YEAR- IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACT. THE DOLLARS THAT WORK LATE
INTO THE NATURAL RESOURCE
PACKAGES INCLUDING WILDFIRE
PREVENTION WHY RESILIENCY
CLIMATE RESILIENCE. AND
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE- YOU
KNOW INCLUDED FIVE POINT TWO
BILLION. OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS TO SUPPORT THE MEDIA
DROUGHT RESPONSE AND LONG TERM
WATER RESILIENCE AND THAT'S WHAT
MANY OF THESE COMMUNITIES THAT
YOU UST PRODUCT DOWN SOUTH.
HAVE BEEN WORKING TOWARDS IS
THAT LONG TERM WATER RESILIENCE.
THE FUNDING ALSO NEARBY- LOOKING
AT GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS I WAS-
WHAT THE TOWARD THAT. WE WERE
HEARING ABOUT- WHAT WHAT THE
PRODUCT AT THE PROJECT UNDER THE
WENT AWAY PROGRAM IS THAT BROWN
SUSTAINABILITY. AND ECONOMY IN
DIVERSIFYING FOR WATER
PERSONALLY I'LL TALK TO SAN
DIEGO ABOUT HOW THEY HAVE
DIVERSIFIED THEIR Y. PER FOLIO.
SO THESE ARE THE THINGS THAT WE
WANT. TO CONTINUE TO INVEST IN.
WE ARE PROJECTS THAT WE TO COULD
TO SUPPORT. ASKED ME. IN AND WE
- ARE YUP THAT. THE HISTORIC AND
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE OVER THE
PAST YEAR THIS IS. WE WANT TO
MAKE CALIFORNIANS RESILIENT AND
TO MAKE CONSERVATION A WAY OF
LIFE HERE. THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND THANK YOU FOR HIGHLIGHTING A
COUPLE OF TIMES THE- INNOVATIVE
WORK THAT IS COMING OUT OF SAN
DIEGO YOU HAVE READ THE ROOM
QUITE WELL. SENATE-ROOM THIS IS
SENATOR THANK YOU WELL I YOU
KNOW WATER IS ONE OF OUR MOST
IMPORTANT RESOURCES AND- THOSE
OF US WHO'VE LIVED IN CERTAIN
AREAS THAT HAVE LIVED THROUGH
SOME PAINFUL DECISIONS THAT
ALLOWED US TO HAVE A DIVERSE
PORTFOLIO- INCLUDING STORAGE. DE
SAL CONSERVATION- IT AND ARE
PURE WATER PROJECT AS WELL SO IT
ANY RIGHT THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
ALLOWING ME TO GLOM ONTO YOUR
QUESTION. SENATOR GROWTH WANNA
LET YOU TAKE IT FROM THERE.
THANK YOU COULDN'T GET AFTERNOON
MISS MORGAN HOW ARE YOU. GET
AFTERNOON SENATOR I REALLY WANT
TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE-
TIME THAT YOU SPENT WITH ME AND
I KNOW THAT WE'VE BEEN PLAYING
PHONE TAG OVER SOME FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS BUT I DO WANT TO TELL
YOU THAT- I THINK YOUR OPENNESS
AND- ALL THE CONVERSATIONS THAT
WE HAD. A YOU KNOW THE LINK THE-CONVERSATION THAT WE HAD I
THOUGHT WAS VERY INFORMATIVE AND
I REALLY APPRECIATE AND THE ALL
THE INFORMATION THAT YOU
PROVIDED ME AND I DON'T SEE
HONESTY I KNOW THAT EVERY
INDIVIDUAL IS HONEST WHEN THEY
CAN BE FOR THE SPORT BUT YOUR
HONESTY AND INTEGRITY AND JUST
THAT. THE WILLINGNESS TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THINGS THAT
DON'T REALLY GET A CONVERSATION
PIECE A GOING USUALLY IN THIS
ARENA SO I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT AND I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU. M. I KNOW THAT YOU WERE
GOING TO FOLLOW UP ON A COUPLE
OF ISSUES WITH ME THAT I BROUGHT
UP REGARDING THE DISTRICT. I'LL
SAVE THAT FOR A PHONE CALL. BET
AND- AS- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I DIDN'T WANT TO TALK DOWN AT
TALK ABOUT WHICH WE DID TALK
ABOUT IN THAT. IN OUR
CONVERSATION IS THAT. YOU KNOW
GIVEN THE DROUGHT IN THE
CUTBACKS WITH THE CENTRAL VALLEY
IN OUR FARMERS AND GROWERS. YOU
KNOW I AM LIKE I SAID I'M A BIG
PICTURE PERCENT AND- MY
COLLEAGUE THE FORMER SECRETARIES
RT ROLLING HIS EYES AT ME. BUT
M. ARE YOU. AYE HE IS. HE IS
ROLLING HIS EYES AT ME BUT HE'S
SO I'M- YOU KNOW I'M VERY
CONCERNED YOU KNOW- I TALK TO
YOU ABOUT THIS WE WERE ON THE
PHONE THERE ARE SEVERAL PRODUCTS
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY THAT WE
GROW ONLY IN THE CENTER VALLEY
AND THEY'RE- AROUND THE GLOBE.
THEY DO NOT GO ANYWHERE ELSE.
THINGS THAT ALL OF US ON THIS
DIET CENTER CONSTITUENTS EAT
EVERY DAY. ALMONDS ALMOND FLOUR.
AND KIWIS QUARTERBACK CARROTS
AND ALMONDS WALNUTS PISTACHIOS.
I BELIEVE THERE'S A HUNDRED
TWENTY COMMODITIES I WON'T NAME
THEM ALL. AND BUT WE GROW IT IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND WITHOUT
WATER WE OBVIOUSLY CAN'T GROW
THAT. SO THINKING BIG PICTURE
WHAT'S YOUR THOUGHT PROCESS OR
WHAT YOUR THOUGHT- ABOUT WHERE
WE WILL GET THIS FOOD IF WE
DON'T GROW IT IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND PROVIDE WATER TO THE
GROWERS THAT GROW THE FOOD IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE AGAIN. THE
TOP THREE FOOD PRODUCING
COUNTIES IN THE ENTIRE WORLD.
OUR. FRESNO KERN AND TULARE
COUNTY. THANK YOU SENATOR I
THINK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
ADVOCACY IN THIS AREA. YOU KNOW
IT'S A- IT'S A QUESTION THAT I
DO NOT HAVE AN ANSWER TO AT THIS
TIME POWER IS ONE THAT I WILL
CONTINUE TO LEARN MORE ABOUT
THAT OUR COMMUNITY NEEDS. AND I
WILL BE HAPPY TO SHARE WITH YOU.
WHAT I LEARNED WE ARE CURRENTLY
TALKING WITH OUR SISTER AGENCIES
INCLUDING THE DEPARTMENT WATER
RESOURCES AND THE PAIR
RECLAMATION. SO WE CAN'T ANSWER
THESE QUESTIONS. APPEAR
RECLAMATION AND YOU WRBL MEANS
OUR BOARD MEETING SOON TO HELP
US FURTHER UNDERSTAND. WHAT OUR
WATER HERE LOOKS LIKE IN
DETERMINE IF ADDITIONAL ASK OFF
THE BOARD AND IF SO. WHERE.
THOSE ASSOCIATED IMPACTS. I
APPRECIATE BIG PICTURE QUESTION
. THEY HELP ME. VICE THE CALLERS
MAY NEED TO FOLLOW UP WITH.
HUNDREDS THAT PICTURE AND SO
AGAIN YOU KNOW I REALLY.
APPRECIATE THE SACRIFICE. THEY
REALLY DO OPEN UP ADDITIONAL
DOORS FOR ME- LINES OF THOUGHT.
PLACES FOR ME TO REALLY DO YEAH
AND FOLLOW UP ON SHE GOT I'D
ALSO LIKE SOME FOLLOW UP IF YOU.
I'M JUST I A COUPLE OF THAT WE
DID TALK. CONCERNED ABOUT THE
FOOT SUPPLY CHAINS LET'S JUST
SAY WE DO GET YOU KNOW FOOD FROM
VENEZUELA- YOU KNOW HOW'S IT
GONNA GET HERE ESPECIALLY WITH
THE SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE I THINK GROWING FOOD SAFELY
HERE IS THE BEST THING BUT
THAT'S THE AREA THAT I REPRESENT
BUT- EVEN IF I WAS IN THE-
LOVELY CITY OF LOS ANGELES OR IN
SAN DIEGO THAT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER I WOULD STILL WANT OUR
FOOD. GROWN HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- BECAUSE WE WOULDN'T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THOSE TYPES
OF SUPPLY CHAINISSUES AND
OTHERS IF WE WERE ABLE TO DO
THAT- I HATE THAT WATER IS I
HATED EVERYTHING IS VERY
POLITICAL BUT I REALLY HATE THAT
WATER IS POLITICAL. THERE IS A
TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN
BIOLOGICAL OPINION BY A PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION THAT OPINION IS
NOW AND IN THE FRESNO CORD TO
LAWSUITS BEEN FILED INTO AND IT
DEALS WITH OUTFLOWS SEEN THAT
THE NEW BIOLOGICAL OPINION WITH
NEW SCIENCE SHOWS THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TO HAVE SO MUCH OUT FLOWS
TO PROTECT SALMON AND- SOLIDITY
FROM COMING INTO THE BAY AREA
WHAT'S YOUR THOUGHT. ABOUT THAT
OR CAN YOU EVEN. COMMENT BECAUSE
IT ISA LAWSUIT. AB SO WHAT
WOULD THEY BE A LOST. I CAN'T
CALL. ON IT AT THIS TIME HOWEVER
YOU KNOW IT IS SOMETHING THAT
GETS ME OUT. THESE ARE THINGS
THAT ADDRESS BECOMING A BOARD
MEMBER OVER THE- PAST EIGHT
MONTHS. I AM ASKING QUESTIONS
ABOUT I AM READING. GETTING THAT
UNDERSTANDING- SO THAT. AS WE
MOVE FORWARD AND THESE. ITEMS
COME TO RESOLUTION. I CAN BE I
AM KNOWLEDGEABLE OF THOSE THE I
LOVE. HOW WE GOT HERE- AND SO AS
WE MOVE FORWARD I EAT. CANACCORD
WITH THAT KNOWLEDGE I CAN AFFORD
POSSIBLY. I CAN- YOU KNOW. WHAT
YOUR YOUR QUESTIONS NO ASHER
ASKING L. ABOUT THE SUPPLY
CHAIN. YEAH WILL ALSO INCREASE
MINE IS JUST YEAH. THANK YOU
YOUR BROWSER. PICTURE QUESTIONS
- I CALL THEM SOMETIMES THE I
NEED. CONSEQUENCES OF ACTIONS.
AND SO. I THE THAT'S WHERE I
WANT TO WORK WORK I LIKE THE BIG
QUITE I LIE THE THESE GUYS AND-
TO SO THAT I CAN. HAVE A GREATER
UNDER. AND I CAN THE NEW YORKER
THERE WAS. HI WHERE I WORK WITH
OTHER ONLINE WE CALL CROSS MEDIA
IMPACTS AND IT'S JUST IT'S RIGHT
THERE ARE. YOUR QUESTION IS
RIGHT THERE WHAT WHAT THE AFTER
IT IS RELEASED WHEN WE MAKE IT
THE- WHEN THE OTHER IMPACT. NOT
JUST TO WILL AT THE OBVIOUS AND
- TO LOOK AT THAT ARE NOT SO.
AND HAPPENS OF THOSE SO THAT WE
TRULY ARE MAKING THE BEST
DECISION THAT WE CAN'T AND
THAT'S THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT
I TRULY BELIEVE IN AND THAT YOU
KNOW WHY YOU'RE TAKING NOTES
HERE AND I DO KNOW WE HAVE NOTES
FROM OUR- THE OTHER
CONVERSATION- HAVE NOTES HERE
YOUNG TALENTS IT. DOES NOT. I
TEAM AND- ON EARLY. AND AS WE
AND YOU KNOW ZERO FIVE THE
CORNER AND ASKED WE KNOW THROUGH
NOT JUST THROUGH THIS WATER YEAR
WE LOOK TO FUTURE ONE YEAR. MAKE
IT. DECISIONS HE SAID. THANK YOU
MAY I REALLY A YOUR CALL THAT
ARE SIMILAR THAT YOU GAVE ME THE
OTHER DAY ON THE PHONE NAY MADE
IN PUBLICLY AND I DO APPRECIATE
THAT VERY MUCH I YEAH. I DO
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED SALMON AND
YOU KNOW THERE'S NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATER THAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE- OR IT NEEDS TO. BE
THERE FOR THE PURPOSES OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THERE'S A VAST
NEED FOR WATER- THERE WAS A
COMMENT MADE A PROP- THERE WAS A
PROPOSITION THAT WAS THE BALLOT
MEASURE THAT WAS PASSED PROP ONE
SB ONE I BELIEVE. IT WAS A
BALLOT MEASURE THAT ADDRESSED A
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
THAT WE HAD A COMMITTEE HEARING
YESTERDAY IT WAS VERY
INTERESTING TO ME TO LEARN A FEW
FACTS AND I WANTED TO GET YOUR
TAKE ON IT. AND SO THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA APPROVED
A BALLOT MEASURE TO FIND WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS. IN YOUR
OPINION CAN YOU CHANGE. WHAT THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA VOTED ON TO FEND AND
DIRECT IT TO SOMETHING ELSE OR
DOES IT HAVE TO BE FUNDED AND-
THE WAY THE PROPOSITION WAS
RIPPED WRITTEN AND IF YOU. IF
YOU NEED TO GET BACK TO ME ON
THAT I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND AS
WELL. YOU KNOW Z. I DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN- SO I. BURKE
BUT IN THE CONTEXT OF WHAT WAS
PROVIDED TO ME. THANKS TO THE
STATE WATER BOARD AND JUST BE
INVOLVED IN IMPLEMENTING THOSE
FINES- YEAH WE TAKE A LOOK AT
WHAT WE TAKE A LOOK AT THOSE
TIMES AND WE NEED TO READ WHAT
IS PUT INTO YOU KNOW IT'S A LOT
AND WE RAISE THOSE IN AND WE DID
ALSO PREPARE- YOUR BY LINE'S.
THIS IS HOW YEAH HERE'S WHAT WE
READ THAT IS LAW HERE'S WHAT OUR
GUIDELINE IT WOULD TAKE US TO
THE BOARD- AND- THEN. THE FOURTH
QUARTER YEAH PUBLIC COMMENTS AND
SAYING. HERE'S HOW WE GOING TO
DISTRIBUTE THOSE FINE. SO IT'S
VERY PUBLIC PROCESS I'M DOCTOR
THE BOARD IN A TOP THOSE
GUIDELINES IN THEN WE IMPLEMENT
THE FUNDS BASED ON NOT- AND SO.
THAT'S THE PIECE THAT I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN- IN. THAT IS SO.
OUTSIDE OF THE ARE YOU ARE WE
NEED TO DO IS FOLLOW UP TO SEE.
YOU KNOW GENERAL BE MORE TO- YOU
KNOW THE DISCUSSION THAT WAS HAD
YESTERDAY ENDS YOU UNDERSCORE WE
UNDERSTAND YOUR WHAT IS THE
CONCERN. I'M SO THAT I CAN A-
YOU'RE TRULY ANSWERED THE
QUESTION AND UNDER BASED ON WHAT
THE CONCERN THAT WAS RAISED.
THANK YOU MA'AM AGAIN I TRULY
ENJOYED OUR CONVERSATION I LOOK
FORWARD YOUR CONFIRMATION. I
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING YOU-
I APPRECIATE WHAT I HAVE TO CALL
HONESTY IF YOU DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THE QUESTION YOU DON'T
TRY TO SPEND ANYTHING YOU'RE
JUST LIKE ALL FIND OUT. AND I'LL
GET BACK TO YOU AND I THINK THAT
IS A SPEAKS VOLUMES OF YOUR
CHARACTER IN WHO YOU ARE. AS A
PERSON AND I THINK THAT AND- AT
YOUR LITTLE BOYS VERY BLESSED TO
HAVE A MOTHER LIKE YOU SO AM I
LOOK FORWARD AGAIN TO
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU SENATOR.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROVE- SENATOR
LAYERED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR AND- I CANNOT ARCH
MY EYEBROWS TO ROLL MY EYES. SO
I JUST WOULD SAY THAT THAT'S NOT
WHAT WAS GOING ON AND- IN A MS
MORGAN THANK YOU FOR THE VISIT
AND BEING HERE AND THE
INTERESTING THING IS YOU'RE JUST
HAVING THE MISFORTUNE. OF HAVING
YOUR CONFIRMATION HEARING TODAY
AFTER WE HAD THIS OTHER HERE.
THE ED AND PRIVATE WE ARE THE OF
THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
BAKERSFIELD BY HAD EXCHANGE
WHERE SHE LET ME KNOW THAT. THAT
YOU JUST COULDN'T HAVE
VEGETABLES SALMON WITHOUT
VEGETABLES AND I SAID YOU
COULDN'T HAVE VEGETABLES WITHOUT
SALMON SO WE WERE. GOING BACK
AND FORTH IN A WONDERFUL WIFE.
AND JUST FOR THE RECORD I DON'T
THINK ANYBODY CAN CHANGE THE TWO
POINT SEVEN. BILLION DOLLARS FOR
STORAGE I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE
VOTERS DID. I THINK IT'S LOCKED
IN AND- UP- AND I'M SORRY THAT
IT'S EVEN COMING UP. FOR
DISCUSSION. I THINK THAT THE IT
PART OF THE DIFFICULTY IN THE
HEARING OR HAVING IS THAT- WERE
QUIZZING YOU. ABOUT A LOT OF
ITEMS THAT THAT ACTUALLY FALL IN
THE PURVIEW OF THE AGENCY I ONCE
HAD OUR BECAUSE- WE'RE REALLY
TALKING ABOUT WATER SUPPLY AND
EVEN FISH AND WILDLIFE TOGETHER
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES TO THE FLOWS. AND THE
WATER MORE TAKES WHAT COMES FROM
THAT. AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS THAT YOU MADE AN
ABOUT YOUR OPENNESS BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S THE OPENNESS TO DEAL
WITH THAT THAT IS GOING TO BE
THE IMPORTANT THING. FOR GOING
FORWARD. AND I THINK THAT THE
MOST OF MARK. ASKED DIFFERENT
QUESTIONS I WANTED TO ASK IN
PARTICULAR. SENATOR COM LONGER
ARE ASKED ABOUT ENGINEERING AND-
WE SHOULD JUST NOTE THAT THIS IS
A SEAT. THAT IS HELD FOR CIVIL
ENGINEER AND THEY ARE VERY HARD
TO FIND OF THIS IS BEEN A
DIFFICULT RECRUITMENT THING SO
THE FACT THAT YOU. ARE HERE IS A
GREAT THING AND A TRIBUTE TO
YOUR QUALIFICATIONS AND YOUR
BACKGROUND AND THAT WAS EXPLORED
WITH YOU THERE. IN THE END
THERE'S ALREADY BEEN A QUESTION
ABOUT MOVING THE PROCESS
EXPEDITIOUSLY WHICH I WANTED TO
ASK ABOUT. SO LET ME JUST TEST
THE LAST ONE THAT I'M SURPRISED
NOBODY'S ASKED ABOUT YET BECAUSE
YOU MENTIONED ABOUT TWO OR THREE
TIMES. PETITIONS PARTICIPATING
IN THE RACIAL EQUITY WORKING
GROUP SO WHAT IS THAT MEANT
BECAUSE I KNOW THEY'RE BEEN
CRITICISMS OF DIVERSITY AT THE
WATER BOARD. ABOUT HOW IF YOU
DROP DOWN ON THAT AS A PART OF
THAT GROUP. I'M SURE SO YEAH SO
YEAH WHEN I PARTICIPATE WITH
EARLY STAGES AND IT WAS BEING ON
A CALL. BACK FINDING- ONE- YOU
KNOW A GROUP WAS BORN SHE'LL.
HAVE OPEN CONVERSATIONS TO
UNDERSTAND- YOU TO GET INPUT
FROM STAFF THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
HELLO SHOULD NEVER COME FORWARD.
AND SO HARD THAT WAS WORKING ON
THE RESOLUTION. ON A GROUP- THIS
GROUP WHAT FORMED TO WORK THE
REST OF. ON I WAS MOST INVOLVED
IN WISE HOLDING THE EXTERNAL AND
INTERNAL LISTENING SESSIONS TO
REALLY HEAR CRIME THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE SERVE HOW
CAN WE DO BETTER WHITE. YOU GET
GIVE US YOUR WHERE. WHERE ARE WE
NOT ONLY SERVING THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND WHAT DO YOU WHAT
DO THEY WANT TO HEAR FROM US-
HOW WOULD THEY LIKE THOSE TWO
HOW SHOULD WE EACH UNIT CAME IN
WITH THOSE COMMUNITIES. AND ALSO
FROM OUR STAFF BECAUSE WE NEED
WE NEED QUALIFIED WE NEEDS
STAFF- BALLOTS OR- NOT JUST
DEDICATED TO THE WORK THAT ARE
FULLY ENGAGED NOW AND YOU'LL
HAVE A HIGH MORALE WITHIN THE
AGENCY- YOU KNOW THAT WE ARE
RETAINING STAFF- SO MANY THERE'S
SO MANY. PIECES TO THAT- SO
WE'RE THAT WE CAN'T POLICE THANK
YOU ALL CAN WITHIN. AND SO
CALLED ME THAT THAT DISCUSSION
IN TURN. HOW DOES. COLLECT DATA
. SO THAT ASK MOVE. WE CAN. AN
ACTION. TO TO ADDRESS EIGHTY
WHAT YOU'RE WHAT COMES OUT- IT'S
SO I WAS A BOY MOST HERE IN THE
AND. HEARING FOR AND FOR. THOSE
DON'T THOSE LIST SUCH. AND NOW
THAT IT YOU KNOW I AM NOW ON THE
BOARD IT WILL BE. ASK THAT-
ACTUAL STAFF WORK ACT PLAN- CHIU
JUST YOU KNOW I YOU AS HUNDREDS
. BACK AND- YOU KNOW I HEARD WAS
SAID FROM THE PUBLIC I SAID IN
ON SOME THOSE LESSONS. AND HERE
TO FEED JUST ENSURE THAT FAST
ENOUGH IS TAKEN AND IT IS QUITE
INTO AN ACTION PLAN SO THAT WE
AT. WE CAN APART. THAT THE INTO
RTC MAKING. FOR THANK YOU FOR
THAT RESP AND I PER. I THINK
YOU. A YOU BRING A SPECIAL IS
HAVING OBSESSED LEVEL AND THEN
THE BOARD NOW REALLY MAKE AND AS
I SAID EARLIER THERE IS SOME OF
TO BACK TO LAST BECAUSE- OF
THINGS COVER SO- THING YOU FOR
YOUR- I LOOK FOR TO SPUR YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR. WELL THANK
YOU TO MY CAR- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE AND YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE IN THESE
ISSUES AGAIN WATER IS OUR
GREATEST RESOURCE IN THE STATE
AND THE DROUGHT HAS SERIOUSLY
IMPACTED THAT I THINK EVERY
STATE NEEDS TO HAVE- CERTAINLY A
PLAN THAT LANDS INTO THE MASTER
PLAN I'M NOT THE FORMER
SECRETARY BUT EVERY PART OF OUR
STATE HAS TO HAVE SOME
UNDERSTANDING OF WATER. AND THE
SPECIFIC ISSUES TO EACH
GEOGRAPHICAL REGION BUT HOW IT
ALL FITS TOGETHER SO WE TALK
ABOUT WATER CURTAILMENT IN THE
DELTA FOR INSTANCE THAT'S GOING
TO HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE REST OF
THE STATE WHEN SAN DIEGO WHICH I
AM PROUD TO SAY IS FIGURE OUT
HOW TO HAVE A DIVERSE PORTFOLIO
THAT HELPS AS WELL BUT- WITH THE
DROUGHT- YOU KNOW I THINK I TAKE
ALL OF OUR POSITIVE ACTIONS HAS.
REALLY BEEN TESTED AND SO I
THINK THE CHARGE AND CHALLENGE
FOR THE BOARD IS TO FIGURE OUT
ANY ACTIONS IT'LL HELP MITIGATE
ADVERSE IMPACTS ON THINGS LIKE
AGRICULTURE AND OTHER USERS- SO
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
PROBABLY ANYTIME SOMEONE COMES
BEFORE US FOR THE WATER BOARD I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO ENGAGE THIS
CONVERSATION- BECAUSE IT IS SO
CRITICAL TO ALL OF US. THAT'S
THE STATEMENT I DON'T REALLY
HAVE ANY. COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FURTHER BECAUSE I KNEW I COULD
COUNT ON EVERY SINGLE MEMBER OF
THIS COMMITTEE TO- TO ENGAGE
FULLY AND I JUST APPRECIATE THE
FACT I THINK WE NEED. EXPERIENCE
I THINK WE NEED TECHNICAL
SKILLS- AND A BROAD RANGE OF
SKILLS TO SERVE ON THIS BOARD TO
HELP US FIGURE OUT SOME OF THE
SOLUTIONS SO THANK YOU FOR
ANSWERING ALL THE- QUESTIONS OF
MY COLLEAGUES. WITH THAT I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD AND GO TO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH TO SPEAK.
AND I'M GOING TO START OFF OF
COURSE WITH MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. IN HIS ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE AND LET ME SEE IF
WE HAVE PEOPLE HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK. OKAY- SEEING NO
ONE APPROACH AND THE- THE PODIUM
I WILL THEN GO TO OUR MODERATOR
. TO WELCOME HIM BACK AND- GO
AHEAD AND PUT ON THE SCREEN
AGAIN I'M SO SORRY THE
PARTICIPANT NUMBER. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX
THREE. AND THAT ACCESS CODE IS
SEVEN SIX THREE SIX TWO EIGHT
THREE THREE MISTER MODERATOR
WELCOME BACK AND WE WILL IT-
GLADLY TAKE PEOPLE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT FROM THE PUBLIC
. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE POINT ZERO AT THIS
TIME. GOOD FOR FIRST LINE OF
SUPPORT FROM MEMBER BLAMES
FOURTEEN THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON TO DETECT QUICKIE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES ARE QUITE IS PLEASED TO
SUPPORT SENATE CONFIRMATION A
BOARD MEMBER OF MORGAN'S
APPOINTMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR MODERATOR NEXT
WITNESS. OVERLAYING SIXTEEN IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR STEVE BAKER WAS
ERROR RIDDEN SO SINCE
REPRESENTING THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT. WE'RE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT MISS MORGAN FOR HER
CONFIRMATION AND CLICK HERE ALL
THE CONVERSATION ABOUT ENGINEERS
AND HOW IMPORTANT THEY ARE TO
THAT WORK THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER BAKER NEXT WITNESS.
MACKEREL AND FIFTEEN BERLIN IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MY NAME IS MARY AND THE DIRECTOR
OF CLEAN WATER ACTION AND SOME
OF THE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNITY WATER THROUGH AMERICAN
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND WE
ALREADY SUBMITTED A LETTER TO
ALL BE GREAT. WE WORKED. A
MORGAN WHEN SHE WAS TRAFFIC THE
OPPOSITION WHAT WATER POLLUTION
AND WE BOTH TRIED AND TO MEET
WITH HER STUDENTS. WAS A TO THE
BOARD AND WE IT BACK TO BE FAIR
AND OPEN AND IT SHOULD GIVEN THE
AMOUNT MONEY THAT WATER WILL BE
. BOTH STATE FEDERAL FUNDS
SOURCES OVER THE NEXT YEARS HER
EXPERIENCE IN PRODUCT MANAGEMENT
DELIVERY WILL BE VERIFIED TO THE
BOARD CHARGED. FOR THANK YOU. HE
VERY OTHER WAY MISTER MATER. WE
HAVE NOTICED AND THIS TIME THANK
YOU WE'LL BE BACK MOMENT. LET ME
COME BACK THE ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINE ONE SEE IF WE HAVE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. OKAY SEEING NO
ONE MISTER MODERATOR LET ME COME
BACK TO YOU TO TEE UP ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
IT OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I'M SURE
WE HAVE NO IN Q. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE TODAY
MISTER MODERATOR WE GREATLY
APPRECIATED LET ME COME BACK TO
MY COLLEAGUES- SENATOR LAYERED I
WOULD MOVE THE CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION MADAM
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. GROWTH I DROVE BY KAMLAGER
HI AND LONGER I'D LAYERED.
LAYERED I BATES ALL RIGHT BATES
AYE ATKINS HI ATKINS FIVE FIVE
TO ZERO IT'S FIVE TWO ZERO THAT
IS UNANIMOUS- CONGRATULATIONS WE
WILL MOVE YOUR CONFIRMATION TO
THE SENATE FLOOR AND WE AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
THANK YOU HAVE A GREAT REST OF
YOUR DAY. OKAY THIS CONCLUDES
TODAY'S PUBLIC PORTION OF THE
AGENDA LET ME THANK SAY THANK
YOU TO ALL OF THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY YOU CAN
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING. TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE FOR INSTRUCTIONS YOUR
COMMENTS AND YOUR SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. SO THANK YOU
EVERYONE- FOR YOUR COOPERATION
AND YOUR PATIENTS ARE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON RULES WILL NOW MOVE
TO EXECUTIVE SESSION.